are we in focus me little fuzzy I am big
bird Cookie Monster Danny really where
the daily Danny celebrates 100 episodes
with the cast of the Sesame Street in
the greatest city in the world in the
greatest city in the world
[Music]
guys we did it the daily Denny hit 100
episodes and to celebrate we flew all
the way across country to the Big Apple
and what a better welcome than to sit
down with some famous New Yorkers on one
of the most iconic blocks of all time
I'm to tell you guys it is so exciting
to have you with us what are you guys
learning about over there at Sesame
Street these days that's right yeah
Elmo's mommy and daddy tore down the
your truth people your way that you
would like to be treated absolutely I
think that's very important don't you
think yeah and you can kind of look at
the similarities in your friends but
also you could celebrate the differences
well said I think that's very important
for everyone to know but it's not always
easy right exactly why is important to
be kind you know what else makes the
world a better place cookies okay
cookies you've got cookies your cookies
the cookies are in the green room if you
stick around I'll save you a cookie oh
boy I promise if the cookie I hear you
have a food truck me do God's food truck
they let anybody drive these days
[Laughter]
we get orders from kids and odd then we
get to make the food in the food truck
but sometimes we don't have all the
ingredients oh so we have to go out and
get it and then we get to see where all
the food comes from you know what you
probably met more celebrities than
Entertainment Tonight TAS who has been
her favorite celebrity guest to stop by
Sesame Street I just thought they were
friends stopping by like Kate McKinnon
oh yeah John Legend Oh Ryan came by we
get to see with John
well you know we did a video for never
knew yeah well mr. job is really
powerful
do you guys have a dream guest you would
like or a friend to stop by Sesame
Street who hasn't yet you have her phone
number yes you do will you tell just
never come by let's go right now
yeah we go it's Elmo yeah please come to
Sesame Street
and bring a cookie and bring that's okay
just do the boy sings opera use your
voice oh yeah that's good that's a
chocolate you go get it and just hit
Send that's pretty good okay good thank
you so much for coming hang out with us
what about that cookie oh yeah we'll get
you that cookie a chocolate chip right
yeah chocolate and now a look back at
the daily Denny's best moment
[Music]
those were her babies and this one's
mine so when is this gonna bring all the
boys to the yard
okay did it wait what's your Facebook's
they can all go to you Oh Tyra Banks
about to announce you as the winner what
was going on in your head 30 seconds oh
my gosh I was like just spit it outside
a club free clap back do you think he
crossed the line tonight I just hope I
would have had like cranberry juice in
there are some fantasy and his whole
body would be really sticky
Yanis how did that end did you guys have
some words during commercial break I
told you he was
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
guys this city really is something else
there's no place like it but still I
gotta admit this Cali boy needs to go
home cuz I'm cold thank you guys so much
for watching and thank you for getting
the daily dedi to 100 episodes literally
couldn't have done it without you thank
you for letting me act a fool but of
course be sure to LIKE this video and
comment comment below and let me know
what kind of stories you guys want to
hear what kind of videos you want to see
because even though my name faces on the
show it's as much yours as it is mine so
thank you thank you thank you I can't
thank you guys enough but it's time to
dance our way out of here okay you your
concrete jungle where dreams are made up
I'm Alicia Keys